what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here and it's John here just got done
working out we're going to go watch
spider-man homecoming and a few hours
super late night showing yeah by the
time this video is up our review should
be up simultaneously cross-promoting
piteous isn't a funny how this works cuz
we're going to watch the honest trailer
today from screen junkies or arguably
the best slider man movie though Hannah
Cole a spider based inner - it's going
to be hard to top this one amazing
spider-man 2 it's going to be hard to
top this one I'm telling you guys that
much because it's going to be super hard
yeah man because this franchise ended on
a great note Bryce Dallas Howard Gwen
Stacy man who knew get it cuz that's the
shoes Spider Man 3 leave guys build a
joke you guys don't get my sophisticated
branded a cook leave the joke to Carlos
from a director whose main qualification
for spider-man is his last name I've
ever been to with a spider-man 3 level
of quality five members day they raising
spider-man - hey didn't cinemasins
already do this one you've already seen
the premature reboot to the original
trilogy
now before you see the solo spin-off -
the soft reboot crossover revisit the
crappy sequel to the premature reboot
that failed so hard Spidey swung back
over to Marvel then unfortunately back
over to Sony again not requirement lower
your expectations because the same guys
who wrote star trek into darkness and a
bunch of bad Michael babies are back and
you can bet we'll be good and something
is loved as a kid while including magic
blood it's a void its economize
synthesize the serum from its super
blood in iron man's blood in a movie
it's so grody back added spider-slayer
only get cameos while endings nursing
career has its own bloodline double
shift on Thursday it has to take nursing
classes with 22 year old kids so I can
take you to vote a colleague who asked
for this return to a New York where
everyone exclusively uses so many
products Rashi hahaha grunts play out
and everyone in the city is a scientific
genius except at bay me the stupid
non-scientific
ant and say hello hello to Peter Parker
who has corrected his stutter from the
first movie
um so why'd you want to I'm gonna
compete on a weekend on and replace it
with constantly repeating himself as the
question
that was wait wait wait
clearly they would be there with me
Jeremy watch his relationship with
Wednesday see grow from loving her so
much they had to stay together against
her dead dad's wishes to loving her so
much I stay apart sorry
but they're loving her so much that they
had to stay together again with a
healthy dose of stalking in between just
once the name not minions in part once
more I'm following you now I'm just
going to follow you everywhere thrill as
spider-man faces off against electro a
villain who combines building from
office space tumblr slash fiction blog
you like the time when he falls into a
tank of Evil's he'll get a random grab
bag of electric powers why magneto we
force lightning invisibility and
electric cosmetic industry but for some
reason no actual yield powers I think
good money to watch Jamie Foxx doesn't
ask for his eggs out of his own saliva
that's an eel fact look it up hi I'm
drill as everyone forgets the lesson of
spider-man 3 and cremes even bore
village into an already packed movie
squad the Green Goblin again who's in a
frantic rush to cure the disease his dad
lived with for 60 years no time
Wednesdays East Coast dad and the Rhino
[Music]
a ridiculous Russian transformer who
begins an in fulfill my crab bread on a
poop sangwich so steadily our spider-man
movie with a good performance by Andrew
Garfield that was so bogged down by
subplots underwhelming action trailer
moments with no payoff and the constant
stink of desperation to create a
cinematic universe that writer Alex
Kurtzman did it all over again with a
more are you mother ever how does that
happen
star Oh Tom Holland
oh snap mister barone was back uh
Godiva's dr. Manhattan and Tobey Maguire
spider-man 2 electric Boogaloo that so
you called almost like some well it is
great no but on this Andrew Garfield
maybe you could be only Uncle Ben and
get shot by Kelly McGuire and then he
can fly away in the Japanese spider Zord
well that's the cinematic universe I
could give a hide guy screen junkies is
going to comic-con we'll be covering the
whole event live on screen neji's news
but bigger than ever we're throwing our
own event live Saturday July 22nd at
House of Blues in San Diego we answer
amazing celebrities lined up who you are
not going to miss you can get tickets
now at screen junkies calm slash tickets
that's right go pick them up before
they're gone
but I know a lot of you are like what
I'm not gonna go how am I going to be
able to do this don't worry we got you
covered
we're throwing up sweepstakes we'll
bring out you and a friend put you up
fly you up and join us there in person
gonna be so epic do not miss this
opportunity and get excited for street
leggy central 2017 hell yeah today I'm
Sam Lewis on Google+ we're helping make
this possible
rebel Bob there's gonna be good and I
see they let me get a bonus pizza they
call him Baba Yaga Vega Boyd is better
than despicable behind nothing Wow well
boy was that all 100% accurate yeah
pretty pretty is you know that was such
a terrible film and I was super excited
I still get comments on the trailer
reactions from amazing spider-man 2 or
people like
you know that what were you wrong and
I'm like yeah that's it we'll die roll I
thought something was wrong with me
because I was like I need only one that
feels this way I didn't hear everyone
else's reviews and then I did a review I
think I'm gonna find out this is
actually considered a pretty big
disappointment all right yeah yeah
totally all over the play that that
movie is one of those movies to me that
feels like somebody took a bunch of
elements put them in a box and shook the
box a lot and whatever came out is this
lumpy half satisfying bummer I I did I
just put it together right I was like
the bookend in a way he doesn't I mean
he's not in the prologue when you know
Peter Parker's family go died in that
plane being a rhino at the end he was
the worst I hate in it no it's not a
Jared Leto Suicide Squad oh if he just
had more screen time I would have been
more annoyed if he was in the movie more
I mean I thought Paul Giamatti was
admirably committed but I just I was
just out of it that felt like a
completely different God he was in a
different kind of anomaly and they shot
it like it was a different kind of comic
book moving the same goes for Jamie Foxx
and Dane DeHaan they're all in different
movies is pretty crazy watching Jamie
Foxx like seeing him here when he's not
electro and I'm like oh man you know he
was so cool baby drivers oh yeah I mean
Jamie Foxx is Gooden a lot of stuff
again I admired his commitment but again
it was like it's weird humbling like
wacky characters and all of a sudden
gets really angry and you know some
people really hate it as much as I don't
like amazing spider-man - I do prefer
spider-man 3 over it as much as I don't
like amazing spider-man 2 a lot of
people are really bothered by Denis
Leary ghost dead and why it was it and
what people hated so much is because no
I think I was really the mole of guilt
that he was dealing with the whole time
and that was the one thing where I'm
like I could kind of defend this a
little bit I think I was on the movie
one time so I can't really defend it but
I remember not being bothered by it the
way how everyone else seemed really
bothered by it yeah I mean I at least
liked the idea there are consequences to
his decision not to you know heed his
warning yeah you know haunted by it and
a real ghost either and I can understand
maybe wanting it represented in a
different way or something but yeah it's
just a thing that's happening
movie that was not on my list of
nitpicks I think the biggest
disappointment of this movie was because
of the marketing cordless films
especially they have that that cool shot
in the trivet the final scene of yeah
race we're swings this an animal cover
that'll cover ya against rhino you don't
even get a cool fight that was so yeah
stuff was just was just pointless
and it was shocking how they get
shoehorned so much in because spider-man
3 puts a lot in there but they're not
even doing universe building and then
here they're trying to go for universe
goes yeah I was there Thursday
rhinos let's set up a whole bunch more
stuff and at that point they brought up
about about didn't we learn this from
spider-man 3 and like I felt that at the
time I was like what Intel how why how
did you blow this so hard did you do is
your attention spend your memory that
short Sony I feel like Kurtzman is a
producer writer I don't really see him
as a writer I mean after seeing the work
he's been doing like they worst Michael
Bay phones right there were some Michael
Bay films and then or he has a lot of
familiar and then he did hey didn't do
the last Transformers a minion or
painting in spider-man 2 and then he has
also the mummy and I'm like yeah that
what honest road is brought up that's
such a great point is that the mummy so
representative what also went wrong with
amazing spider-man 2 like he makes the
same mistake again and I and that that
magic blood thing was a good card and
about a little has just a Kurtzman
Harrell oh who knows we're gonna go
watch spider-man homecoming right now
along few hours and I everyone says it's
way better than any of the amazing
spider-man movies it's funny how the
enamels Batman movies are being
considered like the worst there has word
amazing time will tell with all this
stuff I mean like cuz I remember people
disliking the amazing spider-man as much
as they do now the first one even I was
react a lot yeah I mean it's not like me
I do I did to its max to me of like
every time you play Tony Hawk pro skater
as a kid just the second you fell down
you restart the leg that's how I feel
about spider-man right now
like ah it didn't work we just scrapped
everything I'm like no come on just Rhys
tragedy I can't wait to see homecoming
yeah you guys think of what do you guys
think of amazing spider-man 2 if you
actually liked it leave a comment if you
don't tell us your problems or anything
honest trailers Berg did not point out
here subscribe to the real rejects
subscribe to screen junkies first of all
click that notification bell for this
channel that John Humphrey on Twitter an
instant house check out our exclusive
personal rewards on page around people
trust me it's worth it much love check
out our review for homecoming